today I here at CMU supported by K&L
gates thank you to those of you brave
enough and intrepid enough to make it
here at the early hour of 9:00 a.m. we
apologize that we had asked you to get
here so early but we've got a wonderful
incredibly packed day today that we
wanted to be able to just get started
with some of our wonderful speakers in
fact we're gonna lead off this morning
with the recipient last night of the
inaugural K&L gates professorship of
ethics and computational technologies
eleanor Bosch ela is the director of the
community robotics education and
technology empowerment lab for those of
you who were here last night you heard
him refer to the create lab now you know
what the acronym stands for which is
focused on the development of
community-based social and educational
robotics and really transforming
people's lives through community
engagement to identify the challenges
that people face in their lives and the
ways that robotic and AI technologies
can really address respond and spawned
to those challenges and then support
people's abilities to achieve their
goals
and over the years the create labs
programs have engaged over 40,000 people
globally so the reach is not simply here
in the community not simply on campus
not even simply in the United States but
reaches around the globe ILA's been a
CMU faculty member since 1997 is the
author of four books dozens of articles
and holds 13 patents some of which were
part of what led him to have a brief I
believe career as a startup entrepreneur
he's been named a Kavli fellow by the
National Academy of Sciences and in fact
has been inducted into the I wanna make
sure I get this right the June Harless
West Virginia Hall of Fame so I think
probably a distinction that is unique in
this room following ILA's remarks he'll
be joined for a brief conversation by
Tom Simon Knight senior writer for Wired
who was previously the San Francisco
bureau chief at MIT Technology Review
and has written and edited technology
coverage at the New Scientist magazine
and now in his current position at Wired
he covers artificial intelligence and
its effects on the world
without further ado Elin or Bosch thank
you well thank you David for the
wonderful introduction and good morning
all to loosen my jaw and set the stage
some true stories first true story I'm
sitting in a room there's ministers of
transportation and ministers of Defense
ministers of sports from various
countries in the room and the
editor-in-chief of one of the biggest
journalism newspaper companies in the
world gets up and says we've been had by
ourselves when we published the first
story outing fake news I went online to
see our fake news story and on our
online version of our website there's
our fake news story in the middle and
above it and below it there was fake
news because we were selling Adwords and
the people who bought and won the
auction happened - the fake news
purveyors immediately and and he said
you know this is our own fault we don't
even know how to compensate our own
investigative journalism without being
part of a community that we're trying to
say is a disaster immediately gets up
the CEO of the biggest behavioral
analyst company in the world and says I
completely agree with that he just said
that was me I did the article on top and
I did the article on the bottom and
guess what I have a team of machine
learning people who are amazing at what
they do my computer's do hundreds of
millions of a/b comparisons a day and we
know this is a direct quote how to
maximize dopamine response by people and
we know how to make a system that
maximizes this and engages you and
causes you to click through and it makes
me money and I admit that it's not
completely ethical but it really works
well and I challenge any of you in this
room to come up with a better way for me
to make as much money and I'll switch
right away another story a few years ago
gentleman came back from war and started
a
a bar Irish themed pub in Atlanta and it
was a transitional neighborhood where
gentrification was happening but there
were people homeless folks on the
sidewalk and he didn't like this
homeless presence on the sidewalk in
front of his pub so he built the world's
first bum bot bu MB ot robot controlled
by him that would threaten people on
this on the sidewalk with a high
pressure water cannon and a spotlight
and a speaker and it made the news
stories and the stories in the news
which fascinated me were about the
empowerment he had as a maker inventing
a whole new innovative product now fast
forward about seven years last year
nightscope started having this wonderful
robot night scope which is a security
guard that you can rent and have roam
around your establishment night scope
was purchased by an establishment in San
Francisco because the sidewalk in front
of the establishment has so many
homeless people on it and so now we have
a commercial robot used by an
establishment to actually keep people
away from their sidewalk this is where
the story can't be made up it's too good
to be fake
the establishment that bought nightscope
and used it to make sure homeless didn't
congregate on the sidewalk in front of
their establishment was the Society for
the Prevention of Cruelty to Animals no
kidding
go look this up so the SPCA used a robot
to intimidate people on the sidewalk
until by the way San Francisco City
Council made that illegal another one we
talked a great deal about war and robots
and whether robots should in a situation
where there's a war going on make
decisions about taking human life and
it's an excellent and important argument
to have and there's some outstanding
books on the subject
meanwhile in South Korea one of the
biggest electronics manufacturers in the
world made a machine gun activated
turret that's completely autonomous
users near-infrared to actually identify
people and shoot at them and it's used
today to guard some actual
retail establishments and it's already
installed today on the DMZ and it's not
one odd actor there are multiple
companies now doing this in South Korea
as well as in the Middle East now go
back a few years ago let's talk about
drones Los Angeles is testing drones for
one of the first times a few years ago
they had to join up in the sky cameras
down and the police were having a blast
flying this thing around just like your
kids except when they're flying this
thing around just playing with it they
noticed pot they notice the whole
marijuana plantation behind somebody's
walls they went oh look at that
what so they go in and make arrests and
it goes all the way up to the state
Supreme Court because the question is
they didn't have any right to search
they didn't have a warrant well what the
court said in the end was you know what
now that there are drones our assumption
to the right of privacy by having a high
wall around our house actually no longer
applies because drones are commonly
available and they go above things so
you don't get your right to privacy
assumed unless you happen to have a roof
over your marijuana plantation so it's
kind of fascinating that the legal
ramification was to change the rights we
have around privacy because of the piece
of technology that was boundary
technology and fast-forward to a couple
months ago I was in a meeting with the
Minister of Transportation and where the
biggest countries in the world and we
were taking questions from the audience
about drones and people were saying
questions like well what's the
regulatory infrastructure you're gonna
put in place to allow drones to fly and
the answer from the Minister was we have
no idea somebody else has what about
tort and liability how we're gonna deal
with insurance around drones answer we
have no clue nearly every question the
audience asked the answer that was
received by the audience from the
Minister of Transportation for that
country was we have no idea okay one
final true story for you let's go to
cars remember the cute Google car it had
no steering wheel do you remember that
it was steering free why I think we need
to revisit that question because it is
very relevant to what you've been
hearing about in the news today
so the reason they had no steering wheel
is kind of interesting they took a bunch
of pre I
Priuses and put the self-driving
software in it in early days we have to
give come up with some floral form for
it right
and then they trained Google employees
to use these cars and they put cameras
in them to watch the Google employees
and see what they do and the engineers
then reviewed the video footage of this
and they were gobsmacked there would be
an engineer who on their first day on
the highway from San Francisco down to
Mountain View or in the Google
self-driving car cameras there and their
babies in the backseat in the in a
little car seat and you know what
they're doing they're like this the
entire time you so cute the whole time
on the highway there was one guy
memorably who spilled his coffee so for
10 minutes he was like this on the floor
trying to clean the floor while the cars
on the highway barreling down the road
so what did Google do they had a meeting
and they panicked they said holy buckets
people who we trained who're Google
engineers carefully selected for their
raw intelligence of superiority are
doing what their completely trusting the
car well then the answer is obvious we
gotta get rid of the steering wheel we
can't trust people at all that's why
there was no steering wheel in the
little cute Google car now fast-forward
to the accidents you've heard about it
over the last few years dude in Tesla
watching Harry Potter am I getting this
right watching a Harry Potter movie or
listening to a Harry Potter audio drive
running into this side of a truck that
if he was looking up he would have seen
person in car running into a bicycle
where the safety driver is clearly not
paying attention for the couple of
seconds before the crash
in a funny way Google was right their
attempted solution was removing the
steering wheel a very extreme point of
view the back step was let's not bother
with that actual let's just leave it
there and make sure people know as Eric
showed in his video when people should
just take over like that as if people
have the sudden attention to jump into a
high-stress situation and react quickly
which by the way is the opposite of how
pilots work with auto pilots so what
wasn't in the news
in that case is how hard it is for all
of these cars to see bicycles but a
human on a bicycle and our nice thick
legs make it obvious that we are there
but bicycles are a bunch of little thin
frames and the lighter goes right
through them and by the way all those
sensors the robots have are noisy so
when you have little frames reflecting a
little bit of light that's noise if we
were to actually see the bicycles we'd
be on a part of the curve that Eric
showed where we'd have a huge number of
false positives so we avoid that by
hoping to see their legs but that means
person walking with a bicycle is walking
with an invisible stick and that's a
problem so these are all true examples
and I want us to put on our physicians
hats and be a physician for a second and
say that these are symptoms and the
question I want to ask is what are these
the symptoms of and I have a kind of
hypothetical proposition for you about
what these are because I believe these
are all symptoms of one thing and
they're one odd thing that I don't think
we've spent enough time talking about I
believe these are symptoms of alienation
we're creating a world in which we are
alienating ourselves from the reality
we're constructing and there's three
ways in which I believe we're doing this
alienation I want to talk about that now
the first one relates to robotics itself
AI and robotics fundamentally was born
out of the desire to do mimesis to mimic
humanity it was all about this question
of what makes us tick and how do we
cognitively create systems that tick the
way we do how do we replicate the human
miracle in machine form and that's
mimesis it's a one-to-one replacement of
the human intelligence with something
new and maybe that's why they called it
AI which I agree 100% with Eric is kind
of a bad name for it the word artificial
throws us off
fundamentally the first form of
alienation I'm going to talk about is
the alienation from mimesis itself AI
the reality what it is today
has alienated us from that very idea of
a one-to-one relationship or one to one
replacement hypothesis from person to
artificial person we don't aren't making
artificial people by any stretch
in fact if I look at the most successful
AI systems today that I boast about and
I am proud of they have nothing to do
with people they don't work like people
they don't smell like people they don't
behave like people but they solve world
problems I'm gonna give you two quick
examples to give you a sense of how
different these systems are how
alienated from human mimesis first
system I love done by Steve Smith right
here in Carnegie Mellon University East
Liberty all the traffic lights in this
neighborhood have cameras on them now
and instead of having regular metric
counters that decide how long the green
light red light episodes last these
cameras look at pedestrians and they
look at cars and they optimize
beautifully across a network of dozens
of lights the exact pacing of the red
and green lights in such a way as to
minimize idle time in cars and maximize
pedestrian throughput which you get is
much much faster pedestrian walking and
much much less particulate matter in the
air from idling it actually works
something extraordinary like I think 40
percent reduction in local pollution
just from idling of cars I mean
ridiculously cool results but this is an
intelligent network of cameras
responsive to people and pedestrians is
that a human is it replacing a human job
no it has nothing to do with any task
that a human had been sitting there
doing there are no no MS sitting there
hitting lights turning lights green and
red this is a whole new category of
action I'll give you one more example
that comes out of the old lab of Jeff
Schneider and a number of other people
at Carnegie Mellon which is the ability
to do behavioral analytics to discover
dangerous situations they did a very
famous piece of work about seven years
ago looking at purchasing habits in drug
stores and they were able to create
systems that can in advance predict the
onset of pandemics in the United States
like the cold virus by changes in
purchasing habits in drug stores
there was nobody doing that at the CDC
like that
because it couldn't be done it's a big
data analytics problem and they did it
and it took the same system and today
they use it for human sex trafficking so
they're able to actually find elements
of human sex trafficking around the
world by simply taking all of the
community
Media in the internet and analyzing the
massive speed that does not replace
anybody who's doing that work that way
instead it's not mimesis but a whole new
way of thinking about computational
intelligence applied to a real problem
now the second problem the second kind
of alienation alienation from failure
and this is a really big problem we have
an intuition for how humans fail and
with natural intelligence we understand
what failure looks like and what success
looks like and I just explained to you
success does not look anything like
human success in the regime of robots
and AI but guess what failure looks
nothing like human failure either and
yet we have biases that make us try and
suit the the robot failure into the
close of human failure I'll give you a
couple of examples from two friends of
mine Sewer Russell has an example he
uses he shows a picture and in the
picture there's some people and there's
a market and he uses one of the online
image analysis tools and it spits out a
sentence it says a group of people
buying vegetables at a fruit stand and
the people in the onions look at this
and go wow that's awesome that AI system
really knows what's going on in that
picture then you zoom in on the picture
there's no group of people it's one
person there's no fruit stand it's a
bunch of green leaves and yet to you the
human observer when you look at that
picture you love it
rod Brooks doesn't even better one he
shows a picture and the computer says a
group of children playing frisbee on
grass and then he asks the same system
because it is a group of children
playing frisbee on grass that one
actually gets it right so then he asked
the system so can six months olds play
frisbee it has no idea do frisbees taste
good no clue how far do fizz bees fly no
idea that sentence is there because a
statistical analysis that made that
sentence a construct associated with
that picture it doesn't mean that the
computer has any clue what any of the
individuated words in the sentence mean
or what the semantics of that sentence
are in that particular case and maybe it
does and maybe it doesn't but we the
observers have no idea if it does or it
doesn't and yet our failing as humans is
to imbue upon that computer meaning
because it's using human language so
certainly it understands same problem I
have with my colleagues who put eyes and
ears and a smile on their robot and then
when it smiles you in view upon it
effect when that effect is literally
Hollywood so that's the second kind of
failure alienation from failure the last
one is actually the worst one in a way
when I got my PhD we used to deal a lot
with something called non monotonic
reasoning humans make assumptions to
make the world something we can deal
with we ignore irrelevant detail and
think about relevant detail and then we
change our minds if something becomes
relevant that we thought was irrelevant
like oh my car's not starting and I'm
late for an appointment now I have to
start worrying about my car not starting
but I don't spend all morning worrying
about that until it becomes a real thing
so we sometimes call that things like
the closed world assumption we make an
assumption that the world is what it is
and it's kind of static until we have to
change our mind well the problem is we
make that assumption about technology
when I see the boundaries of efficacy
that a computer has I assume that's what
a computer can do that's what AI is
capable of and I will always be wrong
because AI is dynamic it is not static
and what it can do tomorrow is different
from what it can do today and our
ability as a human populace to make hay
of that does not exist we don't
understand how to think about a system
whose capability has changed every day
and that's a fundamental problem is that
we have a static model of a dynamic
system so diagnosis if we are being
alienated from this technology in the
case of success
in the case of failure and by our
inability to understand how it's moving
what is the diagnosis well the diagnosis
is very simple where AI illiterate and
by we I don't mean the wonderful
lawmakers and colleagues that I have in
this room I mean the human population I
mean those who have to engage in civic
discourse nationally internationally so
we're a AI literate and it matters now
compared to 20 years ago because AI is
actually changing the world to its
elections to it marketing and all the
other ways in which a changes the world
and it's funny if you look at you know
very very fast financial trades they
change the world but at least in a
little way we were all read about it on
marketplace the difference is these new
AI systems they change what humans do on
mass they change our behavior
so they're pushing back hard I think the
mistake got made a few years ago when we
invented the phrase stem we really
really messed that one up big time we
invented the word stem we said all our
kids have to learn stem stem is what
matters and we excluded the humanities
completely when what ratters is social
science applied to the computer science
that we do it's the combination of the
two that lets us understand the world
and yet stem excluded that divisive lis
it also took all of these disciplines
and created silos for them science
technology engineering math as if
they're individual areas of learning
that we can optimize and then we know
what to do and we don't because knowing
anything about those four alone and not
transdisciplinary doesn't allow us to
understand the changes in robotics so
I'm at the final part of my talk I've
told you about the problems the
questions what's our treatment and I
believe our treatment is actually that
we have to future-proof
ourself to the dynamism of AI itself we
have to future-proof our population to
the idea that artificial intelligence is
a moving entity and that it will change
and I'll give you an example Eric talked
in his keynote speech yesterday about
not just the fact that these systems
have computational bias but in fact
Microsoft's working on ways to overcome
that by us that's excellent but I
challenge you to show the fluency in the
public to then ask the next question
which is how will those corrective
techniques be tested and audited how
will we know if they work or not
how can the public know that they don't
have the literacy the fluency that we
need for that so fundamentally I think
we need the same kind of fluency for AI
for civic discourse that today we have
around say government people know how
the separation of power works in the
United States they know how elections
work they know what the Electoral
College is everybody needs to have that
undergirding of knowledge so that we can
have civic discourse so we can make
decisions as a community we don't have
that undergirding of knowledge about AI
and that's a fundamental problem so in
conclusion what I'm saying is that we
need fluency and what that means is we
need to recombine a juxtaposition of AI
and humanity we need people to
understand what humanity is
what are the ways in which AI is
actually what I'm gonna call alien
intelligence so I'll give you a new
moniker I'll keep the same acronym to
make it easy so instead of CI I'm gonna
I'm gonna say it's alien intelligence
but I think we need the population to
understand how alien that intelligence
is how unrelated to the human form or
the human failings and I'm gonna give
you an example and pose you with a final
challenge the example I'll give you that
we've nailed recently is climate change
climate change is social and it's
systemic and what the world has managed
to do is come up with markers for
changes in climate the world has figured
out ways to systematize the
understanding of how climate change
affects the world both in terms of
access to clean water access to air
climate induced refugees political
changes due to climate and of course
nutritional gaps due to climate we know
how to visualize this we know how to
quantify this and because we can do all
that we can look 40 years hence show you
the ways in which boundaries are being
pushed in irreversible ways and as a
result what do we have we have the SDGs
the strategic development goes from a UN
we have very explicit and clear
boundaries along which governments can
actually act together because they can
see the possible future that's poor if
we don't do the right thing so that is
how we've dealt with climate change
there's a systematized approach that has
quantified the externalities of how
climate change affects humanity we need
this for AI you know if you take other
ways in which we've changed human
behavior like the opioid drug epidemic
we're starting to quantify that because
it's having such a massive impact on
society like in West Virginia where I do
a great deal of work but we need
precisely this quantified systematized
understanding for the externalities the
ways in which AI changes society so we
can show the boundary conditions and the
knees and the curves where we have to
act as a unified whole planet to enforce
the changes that cause us to stay within
a regime of controlled is acceptable
that means democracy that means personal
agency that means personal dignity and
my final point is mulready said AI is
dynamic fundamentally this means if we
don't do this if we don't create for AI
the same systematize
approach with essentially strategic
goals as we have for climate change we
are otherwise basically lobsters in a
pot of warm water and the water will
gradually warm and will accommodate to
those changes ever so gradually and we
will change and by the time the water
boils we'll have changed quite
thoroughly and quite irreversibly thank
you thank you for a great thank you for
a great tour Gila let's sit down we have
a few minutes here so your talk reminded
me of something you said on stage
yesterday at one point you said that you
were convinced that artificial changes
would change our conception of humanity
and I wondered if you could expand on
that yes I think there's two things that
artificial intelligence does to us that
it's dangerous if it's doing it to us
and we're not recognizing that first of
all it changes our sense of what humans
are unique at and what we derive dignity
from the pleasure of dignity from
secondly artificial intelligence changes
our sense of what's possible
you know we're distracted so much by
stories of things like immortality and
singularity precisely because they
redefine our sense of who we might be
one day I have had CEOs visit me here
who've popped a handful of pills during
lunch at Alibaba and I've jokingly asked
this one gentleman what are you doing
and he said oh I'm part of this life
extension program for immortality and he
was serious and when I jokingly asked
him so how do you do with financial
planning for that hahaha he gave me the
card of his financial planner he said oh
I have a great guy and he does immortal
planning seriously that's the humanity
concept he has has completely changed
you know that's not a Bill Gates who
wants to think about his legacy in terms
of positive impact on the world that's
somebody who believes he's gonna live
forever and that's the world we now live
in is with people that have that mindset
and have levers of power okay and you
have worked with AI and robotics for a
long time and thinking about the
consequences has that changed your
understanding of humanity or your
the sense of yourself I'm guessing you
don't take pills to a forever no I don't
well I think we need to make room for
the next generation in general yes I
think my own sense of self has changed
tremendously I think I recognize that
that we are less good at understanding
what we should be doing in the world
than we used to then I used to believe I
used to believe it was very clear how we
should have a quick career and how we
should kind of Forge your direction and
have impact now what I see is a world
that's changing around us quite rapidly
and dramatically I remember 20 30 years
ago feeling like the world's getting
more peaceful polarity O'Leary's Asians
decreasing things are kind of looking
good my kids are gonna have a better
life than me I don't really feel that
way anymore I feel like we have a
pathway that's rocky and we have to do
everything we can to keep ourselves from
actually ending up in a worse place than
we are in today right okay and you spoke
at the in there about trying to look to
the future and and think about how am i
changing what is being useful exercise
and you indeed wrote a whole book that
kind of took that approach wherever
futures in the East chapter you you
wrote a little fictional skit looking
ahead we were talking about one of those
earlier which you title it mediocracy
can you just introduce this to that yeah
there's one that I called mediocracy
the idea behind that title was the story
story with this idea that a company has
an inventory excess inventory of 50,000
green lawn chairs and the way you deal
with that in this conceptualized future
20 years from now I didn't realize it
was now is you run your behavioral
analytics system create bespoke
marketing copy for every individual
human being on earth that maximizes the
chance that they want to buy a green
lawn chair and you overnight sell your
inventory and it's interesting because
the tails backing you the dog you're no
longer building and selling product that
people need you're simply controlling
the need of people with a giant
universal remote to make sure they buy
whatever you have excess inventory of
and then the point I made was that if we
look not just at consumer choice but
voters choice what happens when people
are able to create highly bespoke copy
for each individual person then
maximizes
chants they vote for the candidate who
is paying the most money for that
marketing well this is now happening I
called it mediocracy because at some
point personal agency has been reduced
to the point where it's hard to any
longer call the system democracy it's
difficult to use that word with a
straight face when in fact people's
political choices are not really being
controlled directly by their brain but
bias system that consists of their brain
and very carefully customized marketing
copy okay so it's kind of it's an
unequal fight right you have this big
analytic machinery working against your
you know small biological system what
what can we do about that have you any
thoughts about how we can level the
playing field and allow us to continue
to be you know real actors in in reality
I loved ocean days talks yesterday in
his spotlight speech I love the idea of
redress I think actually that's a really
important point I think the general data
privacy protection regulations that
Europe is putting in place or something
we should be emulating in the US I
believe we have to create really deep
understanding of the ethics of AI in
humanity basically from lower school
middle school high school all the way
through college so that the next
generation of engineers politicians and
civic leaders actually understand this
boundary technology and I think we need
disclosure you know the forms we signed
today the opt-ins are complete joke so I
think we need fundamentally to rethink
how we disclose the ways in which were
manipulated online the idea that the
biggest marketer can get up and actually
talk about dopamine in the in the view
of the public and not feel embarrassed
about doing that is remarkable that's
drug design it's exactly the same as
designing drugs for addiction and it's
become ok to talk about that right ok
and and you spoke about this this
failure of intuition that people tend to
have artificial systems you know we have
a tendency to anthropomorphize and
project a little bit do you have an idea
of how we can change that Tennessee at a
large scale like it can we maybe we just
haven't had enough time to learn an
intuition for how these machines operate
or fail as you
I actually think that's something that's
on some of you the journalists and I
think you can do an outstanding job of
that I believe you know sometimes I talk
and people say well we can't make
everybody a computer scientist I think
there's a huge huge area in the middle
between making somebody computer
scientists and leaving them illiterate I
think there's really outstanding ways in
which you can teach people the teach
people the failings of these machines
show them how the computational bias for
instance causes errors in
decision-making and we can I think teach
a lot that stops far short of having to
force upon them getting a PhD in the
subject right so I think it's education
and I think it's investigative
journalism that can do that of course
the irony is we have rapidly falling
funding for investigative journalism so
instead we have people who don't get
monetized like the old Huffington Post
writers mmm okay and you also talked
about another failure you talked about
was this this failure from a Mises field
to started out trying to do that and and
hasn't managed it
can we get back to it do we want to is
it something that we should desire it's
an interesting question you know I have
colleagues who are trying to make quite
literally babies the idea is if I make
an artificial baby then I can raise it
and it'll become human in ethical
normative behavior there's a whole hype
of hypothetical there that people hew
toward I don't know in a value judgment
sense that we need to do mimesis I don't
know that we need to replace people
one-to-one the biological desire to
understand how humans work is is
absolutely outstandingly important and
interesting and we should always go
toward that cognitive orthotics will
benefit from that so our ability to help
people have quality of life as they grow
old is gonna be directly impacted by our
ability to do that it's not so much that
the fact that huge away from a basis is
bad as it is we have a tendency to
assume that that robot replaces a human
when in fact it's utterly alien to us
and unless we train people to understand
that I don't think they'll ever have the
the skin to accept that okay and we have
time for more question I'm gonna borrow
one from you yesterday on this stage you
said that everyone had to answer three
questions we have time for just one of
them so one of your questions was
think 10 years into the future what is
something that you were very excited
about hey I'm making possible that we
would improve the world in some way you
know maybe you could take us out on a
high note here that's a great question
so actually the quality of life of an
individual human is probably the thing
that I'm most excited about and so when
I look at everything from exoskeletal
structures that would allow somebody to
walk who were they to fall it would be a
huge change in quality of life but if
this system allows them to walk use
their musculature and if they start
falling it catches them I love that idea
I love the idea of extending people's
personal sense of agency and empowerment
and you can apply that in this
biological sense of you know muscular
exoskeletons and you can apply this in a
core cognitive orthotic sense the idea
that you can have cognitive systems that
work with a human not to replace their
thinking but to help them keep thinking
even as they're thinking degrades I
think is powerfully important to our own
ability to age gracefully and aged well
so to me that's the thing where I
believe those technologies based on the
cognitive side and on the muscular
skeletal side actually will come of age
in the next 10 to 15 years and it's a
sea change right I could go for a walk
with my great-grandfather a hike up a
trail at Yosemite which would be
unthinkable today and that I think is
very inspiring wonderful ok the nice
thing about the positive ELA thank you
so much
[Applause]
people are understanding that robot
systems don't exist in a vacuum that are
robots regardless of what they do are
going to have to interact with humans at
the end of the day these advances that
we're seeing in computer vision where
we're able to very very rapidly detect
people's facial expressions or people's
body posture through things like open
pose have enabled our systems to get the
data that they need in order to
interpret human social behavior and then
on the human robot interaction side all
of these you know many studies coming
out that are trying to understand how
people interact with robots in various
ways and how robots can interpret human
behavior and use their own social
behavior to improve the interactions
between human and robot and so on the
production and understanding side the
human robot interaction research is
going to play a big part my vision for
the future is that technology has a
positive impact we have to answer
questions about how our technology could
be used for good and could be used for
bad and how we can aim our technological
advances toward positive impact in the
world I think this really means that we
need to be multidisciplinary need to
pull in lawyers and policy makers and
people from social sciences and we also
need to pull in people from technology
who understand the capabilities of these
systems and understand what's even
possible to talk about in in terms of
the societal impact
so thanks to Allah for wonderful talk
and Tom for those great questions to
help explore some of these issues in
more detail we're going to shift now
into the second session of the
conference focused on trust so I think
it's very easy for people to focus on
the trust that we might or might not
have in the technologies but one of the
important questions is to really go
beyond that and to think about the trust
that we might have and those who develop
the technology or those who are
deploying and using the technology or
those who regulate and write the laws
about the technology or even more how
technology might change the
relationships of trust that we have with
one another so how can the development
of a new technology change our human
human interactions including those that
are grounded in this really fundamental
notion of trust so I'm going to be
exploring that over the next hour and a
half and through it through a variety of
formats and we're going to start with a
talk by one of our K&L gates
presidential fellows abigail marsh
abigail was a double major in computer
science and mathematics at Oberlin
College in Ohio and is now a PhD student
in the societal computing program here
in the computer science department her
work really is focused on a notion of
usable privacy the idea of how do we
have privacy that is helping us achieve
the ends that we want and in particular
how that arises with adolescents and
teenagers so without further ado thank
you so much and thank you David for the
welcome that includes my undergraduate
education I really appreciate that um so
the funny thing about being a privacy
researcher is that when you see a news
story about some way that technology or
a tech company has violated trust you
actually see through that and you say oh
this is a privacy violation that these
people are really outraged about yes we
frame it in the public is trust but for
example you look at Cambridge analytic
as scandal recently Facebook has
multiple so let's focus on Cambridge and
you see that
what's really being talked about here is
the idea that Facebook would allow
outside parties to collect information
about people who did not consent to it
so they thought that information was
private they thought it was contained
within their social networks and
Facebook servers and they had no idea
that somebody outside of Facebook could
actually be harvesting it and using it
for unstated purposes that the user did
not get to consent to right and you also
see other examples of things like this
we talked a lot about algorithmic bias
and one way that privacy researchers
study algorithmic bias is through
behavioral advertising online behavioral
advertising where the fundamental
question is often how did this website
this advertising network which I've
never directly interacted with on my own
get this information about me to be able
to profile me and sell me these ads
which may be biased in some way as a
woman maybe I'm more likely to see
pregnancy-related ads or mother related
ads and I didn't even know that the
advertising network knew my gender to
begin with right so these trust
violations are actually privacy
violations in my own work I decided to
say privacy is is a fantastic area of
research for technologists but so far
it's really been focused on self
sufficient adults people in their 20s or
30s or 40s or 50s and I'm sorry for
those of you who've been left out of
that but that is the range that's
generally considered worth studying in a
lot of privacy research and there aren't
a lot of people who have focused on the
fact that people outside of that
relatively narrow range of human
experience are interacting with
technology sharing their information
with these websites and with the
software and therefore can experience
privacy violations as well many of you
in this room will have been parents or
if you are parents at the very least you
were a child at one point and you
probably recognize that the teenage
years are very difficult years it's hard
to raise a teenager
especially in today's era where teens
are spending a lot of time online or
spending time with their devices right
and so as a parent it's natural to want
some sort of assistance some sort of
help and there are a lot of software
aids that promise to parents oh we'll
take care of making sure that your child
stays out of bad websites or only uses
appropriate language or something like
that which seems like a miracle fix
right you can't be watching your child's
phone use over their shoulder every
second of the day so great install a
software and do that and these
software's offer a lot of benefits
especially for younger children maybe we
agree that five-year-old shouldn't have
access to pornography right so it's easy
to hit just block all porn and your
five-year-old can use your iPad without
any danger of a weird Google result sort
of like prompting that
birds-and-the-bees discussion a little
too early but it runs into a lot of
issues when we talk about teens and
preteens who are doing a lot of their
socialization and identity formation
online right they're talking to their
friends they're figuring out who they
are and some of that might mean
exploring concepts and topics that are
occasionally inappropriate and in
general might be inappropriate but are
necessary and important in certain
contexts right and there's a lot of
trust violations that these softwares
can pose as a child why would I want a
software like this on my phone how do I
know it's going to respect my autonomy
it's essentially designed to snitch on
everything I've ever done wrong and send
an alert directly to my parent at the
moment of violation that like hey
something is going wrong here you should
go punish your child right and even if
we don't consider the child's feelings
there's still the parents concerns about
trust right these software's can collect
a lot of information about what the kid
is doing with their phone some of them
suggest collecting every text message
the contents of every text message that
your child sends or every social media
message right that means
and and pictures I don't necessarily
want a company to have that data about
me or about my child and these are
concerns that parents have to face when
they choose to install a software like
this on their child's device right we
don't like when Google or Facebook has
this information but we're supposed to
be okay with it when a much smaller less
accountable company does and finally
there are questions of algorithmic
biases a lot of these softwares use ml
to do something like predictive blocking
of content within webpages but how do I
know as a parent that this opaque
algorithm is respecting my parenting
wishes is blocking what it should be and
is not blocking what it shouldn't be so
there are a lot of trust issues here
with technology that involve people
other than than self sufficient sort of
middle range adults who are willingly
interacting with the the software in
question and we need to continue to ask
questions about who is using this and
who is being affected so we make sure to
capture the experiences and the privacy
needs of everybody in our society thank
you so much happy really wonderful and
it's always wonderful to see the amazing
research that's being done by the
students here that it isn't simply
faculty it's the graduate students it's
the undergraduates it's the many people
around this community all engaged in
asking these kinds of questions so for
then for the next part of the session
we're gonna try something a little bit
different and and hopefully it will go
smoothly so we're going to ask three of
our distinguished guests to join us up
here and perhaps turn the tables a
little bit have them not simply be
speakers but also be moderators so what
we're calling I'm calling it a long
conversation and the idea is that we
will sequentially interview one another
for a brief period of time about five
minutes at which point there will be a
very discreet chime to let everyone know
that
going to move on in the next part of the
interview will happen and then we'll
we'll have a much broader conversation
among the four of us around issues of
trust so I'm delighted to invite up
three people
Kirsten vineyard is an expert in
international security policy with over
20 years of experience at the United
Nations she's currently the deputy
director and chief of operations at the
UN Institute for disarmament research
unity R and since 2013 she's led you
Nadir's work on the weaponization of
increasingly autonomous technologies
that sentence came out wrong she's led
the work on trying to understand the
impacts and how we might address the
weaponization she has not been
weaponizing technology herself she also
served as a consultant to four of the
five UN groups of governmental experts
on cyber security Moshe Vardy is the
George Distinguished Service professor
in computational engineering and
director of the Ken Kennedy Institute
for information technology at Rice
University he's a world leader on
automated reasoning and is the author
and co-author of over 500 papers as well
as two books he's received numerous
awards and honorary degrees and is a
member of five different national
academies including the US National
Academy of Engineering and the US
National Academy of Sciences finally
Manuela Veloso is the Herbert a Simon
University professor and head of the
machine learning department here at
Carnegie Mellon University she's
transformed our understanding of social
and collaborative robotics and has also
authored over 500 papers
she was named the Einstein chair
professor by the Chinese Academy of
Sciences in 2012 is a fellow of the
American Association for the Advancement
of science as well as the I Triple E and
triple AI and is a former president of
the triple AI so Kirsten Moshe and
Manuela if you could join me up here on
stage
[Applause]
so start with Kirsten in your view what
is the most important or challenging
aspect for trust in AI and robotic
technologies including their development
and use a nice simple question with only
one answer the only one answer will make
possible all right well I'm coming to
this conversation from an international
security and arms control perspective so
I guess you won't be surprised when I
say that I find the implications of the
weaponization of these technologies to
be a particularly important topic issues
surrounding transparency validation and
verification of algorithmic systems are
among the most important open questions
in AI today and they are equally
important from an arms control
perspective when we start considering
the implications of increasing autonomy
in weapons systems so I'm going to give
you three examples of how Trust in these
systems is challenged by developments in
AI so first we have challenges for
testing and verification of weapons
systems and it's probably pretty obvious
but you really want to trust your weapon
systems these are technologies that are
intentionally designed to do harm right
unlike many of the technologies that we
design and because of that as operators
of these systems you have a moral and
legal responsibilities probably at a
higher level as then you would have as
an operator of a different type of
technology that's not designed to cause
harm and one of the reasons that we
trust our weapon systems is because we
rigorously test them before deployment
and this isn't an aspiration it's
actually a legal requirement under
article 36 of the Additional Protocol
one to the Geneva Conventions so
increasing autonomy and weapons systems
challenges testing I'm due in large part
to issues of predictability
and it's further complicated in the case
of learning systems where the system
continues to learn post-deployment
and then verification which is a very
important concept in arms control we use
it as a stability mechanism verification
so how could international regulation of
military applications of AI be verified
verification usually involves counting
physical objects right so intangible
capabilities don't really work that way
and it's difficult to imagine that
states or even corporations would be
willing to permit inspection of their
code or algorithms and it's questionable
that even inspection would even be
useful at because determining whether or
not an algorithm is quote-unquote
militarized is probably near impossible
right because it's a dual use sort of
situation second example would be trust
by the user so machine learning systems
behave sometimes behave unexpectedly or
in unanticipated ways and in many cases
having AI helped us solve problems in
previously unimaginative AI but as we
become accustomed to AI enabled objects
behaving in surprising ways we're gonna
have one less metric to determine
whether a weapon system is behaving in a
way other than the way the operator
intended so that could be due to
internal error or it could be due to
malicious intervention within the system
and that's going to diminish the
operators ability to intervene or
exercise control and as military systems
become increasingly autonomous and
concurrently humans become decreasingly
present in their operation and oversight
there's a risk that humans no longer
serve as the redundant safety feature
which they currently serve in many
weapons systems I mean I think we're all
we've all know about the many nuclear
near-misses that have been avoided
because a human operator followed their
instincts rather than what the
technology was telling them what's
happening so if a humans no longer
capable of intervening
and oh my finish up that sentence you've
certainly finished the sentence all
right if they're no longer capable of
intervening due to speed or in your
ability to understand the system or
perhaps even worse we've left the human
on the loop marginally just in order to
serve as a scapegoat for technologic
technologies possible failings or
shortcomings and that's problematic so
those are two examples and maybe I'll
get a chance to tell your third I'm sure
there will be opportunities so good to
see much in your view what is the most
important or challenging aspect for
trust in AI and robotic technologies
including in their development and use
so I think it's important to recognize
that we have any situation right now
that we have I would say trust crisis
and and I want to read quotes from two
recent articles appear in the bossing in
fact in the world journal just peggy
noonan last october article somehow
talked about the gun issue and she tried
to explain why people buy guns and
argument I think is very weak but it
doesn't matter for the purpose of this
discussion and she writes because all of
the personal and financial information
got hacked in the latest breach because
the country because our country's real
overloads are in Silicon Valley and
appear to be moral Martians who operate
on some will new postmodern ethical
wavelengths I guess with financial
planning for immortality and they will
be the ones programming the robots that
will soon take all the jobs January of
this year Niall Ferguson most alarming
was the morphing of cyberspace into
Siberia not to mention the cyber
caliphates
a dark and lawless realm were malevolent
actors ranging from Russian trolls
- PO isis twitter users could work with
impurity to subvert the institutional
foundation of democracy if this does not
reflect a crisis in trust i don't know
what is so if we won't talk about trust
we have to stop thinking what does trust
mean so I kind of try to reflect a
little bit on my own personal experience
in in my military service in there in
the Israeli Defense Forces I went to
parachuting training and you jump from a
height of about 1,400 feet which is a
rather terrifying experience I mean you
you're back brain tells you you're going
to die because you're falling off the
cliff and you have to trust the
parachute and you have to trust the
parachute folder that folder it properly
so trust means vulnerability you need
trust when you have a sense of danger
and you're trusting something or someone
to help you face this danger and so
obviously if we're the crisis of trust
it means you're all feeling very
vulnerable and do we trust the
technology that is now providing us so I
think when it comes to cybersecurity
there's no cybersecurity there's either
insecurity it's a colossal failure of us
is a computing discipline as well as
they as they I think as a political
institution around us that we have not
set up better standard for cybersecurity
and now we are talking about do we trust
the day the decisions the machine will
make and we had a lot about equity and
biases and transparency and I have had
very little discussion should we
delegate this decision to machines you
know we are somehow as if we are living
in a deterministic universe in which
it's just determined the machines will
make these human decisions you know now
it's just deciding you know whether
you'll get power or not whether we'll
separate a child from their from their
family when is it going to be sighted
whom are you going to who's going to be
your mate you know will
we already heard everything why bother
with tinder you know we'll let the
Machine decide whom you should you
should go out with and so and the
reality is that people don't like to
talk so much here is that our life are
now with technology is be run by
incredibly large and powerful
corporations total equity of the five
tech companies over three trillion
dollars and one of the things we've
helped before there's no ethics when it
comes to corporations if it's if it's
legal they can do it and it makes money
they will do it we seem to be on this
one is quite a lot right new view what
is the most important or challenging
aspect for trust in iron robotic
technology including little development
and news so I have a more engineering
view of this trust question and more
kind of like I've been quite questioning
how can we do it better at really the
development level so we all want to
trust these machines but eventually we
have to interact with our PhD students
with our students to do PhD thesis to
advance the science of artificial
intelligence and robotics so how is my
dialogue with those students how is my
line of research how is like the steps
that we take to advance our science
going to be different because in fact we
care about trust
so my few remarks are really bringing
you down to not the army not the weapons
but to the moment in which you face a
computer and you have to type if these
than that and you have to program these
machines and you have to help build
programs for which eventually there will
be a change in society so
along those lines for me this question
of trust has to do with the fact that
our AI machinery our machine learning
our robotics machinery has been more of
a problem solver what's the shortest
path and we generate a solution but the
way that we actually function when
writing code when writing programs when
writing algorithms is that we don't have
the challenge of justifying or
explaining why did you say this was a
bottle why do you classify this as a
chair so the explanation part has been
what's present in the old days I mean
and it has been always kind of
underlying their research we even have
teasers on explanation based learning
when we have theses on all sorts of like
analogy trying to come up with like the
similarity between two problems and
justify that resemblance to make
adaptations so but it's not as present
now in terms of actually solving big
problems and still also being able to
justify if needed
and have our algorithms generate such
justifications so my research and my
understanding of trust leads me to for
example have our autonomous robots who
actually navigate in our environments
arrive to our office and be able to
answer in language and not in whatever
language they use internally of numbers
and probability and all sorts of like
functions in language why are you late
and why did you take that route and what
are you going to do next so I believe
that trust comes from the interaction
with the device with the machine and
eventually that machine needs to be able
to be queried needs to be able to be
questioned about the decisions that
actually they made towards solving
whatever problem we asked them to solve
so in that sense for me Trust has to do
a lot with transparency
with explanation with counterfactuals
can we ask a machine what if you had
done something different can these
machine process these type of questions
and be more explicit about whatever
algorithm they are running and what the
solution would be all those scenarios so
transparency and explanation I think are
part of the internals of AI machines
that may enable us to build more trust
in what they do thanks to all three of
you really got got some wonderful issues
out on the table and so I actually would
like to start Manuela if it's okay with
you with what you were just talking
about in terms of the transparency and
explain ability and I think one question
that comes up when we think about the
trust is perhaps transparency for whom
or explain ability for whom because of
course something that would be
understandable or explainable to a PhD
graduate student might be very different
from somebody on the street who doesn't
know as much about the technology so how
do we think about these different
audiences for explain ability it's a
very good question not only the
different audiences but also different
moments in time even for someone that
interacts with the robot or with the
agent many times you don't want to
produce the same explanation today that
you produced yesterday or it's otherwise
it's just you are telling me the same
thing and that didn't help me so we
actually introduced this concept of a
space of explanations a space of
verbalization together with one of my
students eyes of raj and vittorio
pereira and stephanie Rosenthal and we
have been working on this issue about
the the multiple facets of explanations
and in fact trust these levels of trust
is levels of transparency this level of
explanation are not a single entity like
you say a single kind of like concept
and we have done some machine learning
on crowdsourcing people and trying to
understand if someone asks what what
exactly
you happen by the elevator that that
exactly by the hell by the elevator
would be something that would require a
much more narrow explanation as if
someone would ask where you come from
and that's like a language that requires
a different explanation of the mobility
of the machine then what happened by the
elevator so we did a lot of research and
we do as we speak a lot of research on
trying to understand a question from a
human what exactly a means in terms of
an explanation required from the machine
so it seems to me that in a lot of cases
this kind of explained ability if we had
it would be able to to help some with
one of the issues that you raised
Kirsten which was about the difficulty
of verification in rapidly changing
environments where the system might be
deployed somewhere whether on the
battlefield or in the international
context where perhaps it hasn't been
used before so how do we verify that
it's going to work there do you think
that explained ability would be
something that could provide a guide as
we think about sort of how to how we can
build trust in as you said some of these
technologies that can can even have
lethal impacts well used a great word
transparency and that's something that
we talk again a lot about in arms
control as a stabilizing element so yes
I think explain ability is
extraordinarily important at the same
time it circles back to that question of
for who are we explaining to and and
when because when we're talking about
lethal systems sometimes post facto
explain ability it's good to be able to
unpack that right afterwards if
something went wrong but it's it's a bit
late right so explain ability is very
important but I think we should be
focusing more on on thinking about how
do we ensure confidence in the systems
whether they are weapon systems or other
systems before we deploy them
and so explained ability I think is a
much earlier part of the process then
actually post-deployment I mean it's
still necessary and it's part of that
very important human machine interface
that's going to be critical in all of
our AI embedded systems but explain
ability with weapon systems because of
the risk being so high it's I think it's
a bit of a unicorn we need it we need it
a lot sooner certainly as you said the
post factor that that is small comfort
if after the fact you know why that
happened it seems that in many ways that
connects to some of things you were
raised in Moshe in terms of the need to
be able to trust the developers
themselves we can trust men well as
graduate students we can trust Manuela
but as we've been hearing about in
various times throughout this conference
there are companies who are doing things
that perhaps are not out of an effort to
produce technology that will help people
as opposed to helping the bottom line so
could we extend for example this notion
of explained ability to the developers
they have to explain why they did what
they did or what solutions do you think
we might bore paths might we be able to
go down to improve trust in developers
well I think we have to go back to the
questions why do we need trust and when
it trusts because we feel vulnerable
okay and this is true this is basically
human fear if you go if you have a child
I remember being being a child and
walking in it in darkness why are you
afraid when it's dark well because you
don't know what are the threats out
there right I mean so you turn the light
on and okay there's nothing here to
worry about and so human beings are very
vulnerable
we're very fragile okay and so all if
you think about all what all these
things were talking about transparency
and explained ability are all
essentially a way to assuage us that we
don't need to be afraid so this is
really we need to go back is the issue
in some sense it's not so much about
trust the issue is about vulnerability
and fear
and unfortunately what we've been
learning in the more you learn that your
fields are rational they're really you
know just because you're paranoid it
doesn't mean the summer is not trying to
kill you
and what have been learning recently
there are people out there for us no
maybe not to kill us but to manipulate
us and this if you think about this
issue being money manipulated it goes
back to our sense of self and
vulnerability and we feel violated when
we realize we've been manipulated and so
maybe it's not a threat for life but it
is still some kind of a threat to our
own notion of self and self determinacy
and so we start have to figure out I
mean the issue first of all is not how
to somehow make us feel safer first of
all they have to be real safety then we
deal with the psychological factor okay
right now and fourthly we are missing
the regulatory framework that will make
this technological world really safe and
that's why we are fredericks that's why
we have no trust in the system so we
have to go beyond just focusing on the
trust assume that it's a it's a safe
world and you're feeling of fearfulness
are not justified right now I have to
say I think they are justified so we
have to go beyond the trust issue we
have to remove the threat first and then
we have to deal how do we make sure that
people really trust that this is a safe
environment so Manuela would you you
want to switch to becoming a social
scientist and policy maker to remove
some of these threats I'm going to wave
my hands but I actually tend to disagree
with this so you know besides the fact
of of being safe and afraid you also
want to trust a machine that if you ask
you know find me a flight to Paris
tomorrow or get me a good flight to
Lisbon that actually it does the job so
it's just trusting the fact that the
thing is going to do what you expected
it to do or if you have like a robot
around here that you'd say you know go
to the conference room and guide the
visitor back to my office that that's
the case that the robot does not go to
the kitchen or does not go anywhere else
so or my refrigerator if I put something
in the freezer I expect it to
actually freeze the food so there is
something about technology that I mean
for me the trust is that in some sense
also it does what it's expected to do
and I think that that before the actual
solving my vulnerability there is also
this the need to meet the expectation
meet the specification and in AI we are
still not there because we really don't
have like robust robots that we say go
down this road and don't don't go over
anyone we are still trying to find the
the machinery that matches the
specification and what we would like the
autonomous agent the autonomous robot
the autonomous area assistant to do if I
need a man a doctor and I have an AI
assistant that I would like to say and
say go and see if you find any case
similar to these on all the images you
have collected all these data from all
over the world
I would like to trust that the thing
that I'm talking with is a Isis that
does in fact go through all the data in
the whole world and not just two parts
of it to actually answer my question
so the what I believe it's happening
what I believe for me Trust is that the
task that I will interact with is AI
agent to be performed is actually done
the way I expected it to be done so that
kind of like matching my expectations
when I interact with the AI agent is
where I believe that I build that trust
in the machine I want to add one thing
though to the point that these
distrusting the developers do not trust
me do not trust my students and I'll
explain why it's not not trusting but
when just one single thing I'm not going
to put my hands on fire and guarantee
that my robot is not going to hit the
wall or I I just have a hard time
achieving that level of assurance and
and the reason is because the world the
environment
the people are very complex systems it's
extremely complex - from a research
point of view develop a solution that is
trustable for the complexity of where we
want to make our systems autonomous it's
not bad faith it's not like it's not
really intention it's just that it is
too complex it's just too hard and it's
too hard in the sense that there is a
very uncertain system that you now are
supposed to handle with some kind of
like algorithm so it's like the sandy
storm it's like 9/11 it's like all these
complex things that no one was able even
within humans to be able to find a
solution for them they just I mean the
world is too difficult it's too hard on
the other hand are we going to give up
on automating things just because of the
complexity and so what I'm trying to
tell you is like this I believe we have
to accept their AI as humans do will
eventually make mistakes what we might
not want to accept is that it doesn't
improve over time we might not want to
himself is the lack of learning what I'm
saying is that any kind of instance of
something that didn't go well needs to
be more data and needs to be more input
for the eye system in its dynamics like
Allah was saying to become better even
whatever a cognitive assistant you do to
a person if it's not a moving system a
dynamic system that gets better with
experience we are not going to ever be
able to I believe generates some kind of
static system that handles this enormous
complexity and just to finish one
thought I've been doing robot soccer for
20 years so little soccer playing robots
that go to these competitions even after
20 years that is always something that
surprises us in these games with an
opponent robot
there is a verse sri just shoots and
bounces off one of our robots and we say
how come you are supposed to shoot
directly to go not use our robots and
bouncing halls yeah that's what happened
two years ago then last year another one
of these surprises inevitably even after
20 years can you imagine that I go to
these games and I'm still surprised how
these adversaries figure out something
that I did not talk about so that puts
you in this kind of learning curve in
this kind of like trying to minimize the
errors you make and not really assuring
that there are no errors
it's just and of course
perfect predictability and Trust you
know you don't have to have perfect for
the predictability to have trust we
could have for example many of us have
trust in other humans even though humans
surprising each other all the time it's
I think does go to this issue the motion
is saying if we're making ourselves
vulnerable in certain ways and Trust is
relying on somebody else when you're in
that state of vulnerability and I think
it raises all kinds of interesting
questions of course about the weapons
space because is it reason you know
we've got very good reasons to think
they won't be perfect they will make
mistakes of course human soldiers make
mistakes human policymakers make just
make mistakes so when we think about
verification we think about deliberation
about what we as an international
community or a National Defense
organization ought to do how do we think
about the necessity of accidents the
necessity of surprises they're going to
happen is it you know do we do we aspire
to too much if we aspire to we know we
aspire to too much voice fire to
perfection give thoughts about the
relevance of accidents and surprises in
the context of weapons feel free to say
you'd like to pass actually I wanted to
pick up on something my mother was
talking do you mind I'm here talking
about expectations and this is a really
probably quite technologically
sophisticated audience I mean
technologically illiterate but I deal
with a lot of people
don't have a lot of technological
literacy and I I think we're at a real
interesting tipping point when it comes
to this issue of trust and technology
right now where a lot of people have
blind trust we have fear but we have
blind trust in technology and recent
events kick 1 because there's many to
choose from I have I think brought us to
a societal conversation about wait a
minute we need have to go from having
blind trust to having our technologies
the developers of those technologies and
the users and the deployers of those
technologies they need to earn my trust
and we're gonna have to make that
tipping point between blind trust and
earning trust and what are the
mechanisms and what are the tools that
we have to earn trust to verify trust to
have reliable systems predictable
systems confidence in our systems it's
not much more interesting than weapons
earning trust and in fact one of the
things that we are working on now is
like to have these robots actually what
we call verifiable answers so if I ask a
robot how long did it take you to go
from the lab to my office and the robot
says you know two minutes and a half how
do we know that number is right and so
what we do is that we actually have
techniques to decompose that question
and to say ok how much did he take you
from going to the lab to the kitchen and
the robot would say a minute and 10
seconds and now we ask from the kitchen
to my office and if these adapts to 2.5
30 we took 2 minutes and 30 seconds then
you trust that the answer was good so we
are doing a lot of research with
vittorio pereira in his PhD thesis on
this kind of like earning the trust on
finding methods to decompose your
questions so that there if there was a
malware or some wrong answer that you
cannot from a
theoretical point of view randomly
combined so much ever so much malware
that eventually things become consistent
so we are trying to earn trust not only
by explain ability but by checking
consistency of the answers such that
they actually add up to something that
makes sense and after all they are
computing or they are answering
something that overall makes sense and
it's proved to be right and so that's
something that's very new in our
research I mean we barely have started
this but again this is the question of
like when they give you an answer do you
trust it or not so you transform that is
like saying oh if it's giving me this
answer okay then I'm going to trick it
and ask them more questions until I'm
confident that I earned that I mean that
this thing is trust able I'll just put
in a quick plug I think that this is one
of those places where interdisciplinary
work multidisciplinary work becomes
really critical because this idea of
earning trust development of trust
that's that's an area that social
psychologists organizational behavior
theorists have have studied for a long
time so there's a lot of resources that
that can be sort of bootstrapped to
maybe
short-circuit some of these things but
mostly I'm sorry you know we talk a lot
about trusting technology but the
reality is Trust is mostly human
relationship so if I'm talking about the
robot it will come out of manual at
Manuela's lab and I said trust it all
but I really trust Manila to make best
efforts to give me something which is
going to be safe so because I really you
know I most of the time for most people
the technology is kind of a black box so
what does it mean that I trust this
program I have to trust the developer of
this program so we really need to think
about the different actors that are
involved here and to think of trust as a
relationship it's a human relationship
between different actors to a trust
Manuela yes do I trust certain
corporations maybe no do I trust a
developer that I know nothing about
you know I mean partly it's the same
thing you know when when we have a we
feel safe with people we know because we
have gone to rebuild trust between them
you walk into a place where you don't
know anyone and in certain areas of the
world still a stranger every stranger is
a potential risk and so so we have to
start thinking less about the technology
and more about who are the sort of of
characters in this play and what are the
set of trust we can have between them
and one of the sing of course we know in
warfare situation it's a different
situation and we have to see very
differently about trust then we think in
a non-hostile situation but I think the
trust ultimately it's not relation
between human and machine it's a
relationship between humans
well it seems we'll be like humans they
will make decisions they will process
information they will have tons of data
and they will be things you interact
with like you interact with humans so
eventually you may want to also trust
the machinery and not just the humans
will develop the machine I don't
disagree but if I trust my refrigerator
is because I really trust ultimately the
process that led to building this I mean
how does that every filter of mmm I
trust one because it does what it's
supposed to do but I don't think there's
anything nefarious about it that really
the goal is at some point to suddenly
surprise me and give me poison food
because you know I've the people who
built I trust them ultimately so we end
up trusting me trusting machines by by
their predictability if something is
predictably having a certain way which
says okay but also we we intuitively
think about the dose the Actos human
actors involved in this which of course
then raises a whole other set of issues
and complexities around when you have
companies doing this that for good
competitive reasons I'm not going to
disclose how they built the technology
are not gonna how do we get transparency
of those of that sort and I think these
raise an enormous number of questions
and unfortunately I'm getting the red
light that tells us that that our
conversation is coming to a close I
wanted to give you each
one minute if you want to say something
very quickly sort of in closing I just
want to say one thing I saw recently a
very interesting video in New York then
which people were interviewed on the
streets about these things we kind of
mark I accept all those terms of
conditions of iPhones and Facebook's and
all of this and they were horrible the
things we accept and I was looking at
that I mean I was looking at that and
say guess what it was a lawyer
it was a human who generated that thing
and not an AI system
imagine if their texts were generated by
a robot or an AI system which was
fooling me into accepting all sorts of
like horrible things that we accept we
never read that like pages and pages and
pages and whoever generated that was not
an AI system was a human so shame on the
humans in the sense that that's where
like I go back now to what Moshe was
saying but let's educate the humans
let's eventually have the humans make
these things we accept on in terms of
like machinery be trusted trusted
because this Facebook example yes we
didn't accept but how did you know that
in the whole thing that you signed up
for you were not accepting that these
data would go somewhere else I mean I
have no clue you know we just accept so
Humanzee the loop of technology need to
make sure that things are trustable and
humans need to hear make sure that that
is the case I'm sorry for my case but
that's really intimidating the things we
accept in these terms and conditions
it's like oh my god what am i signing
for and somehow it's still not generated
by an AI system and I wonder if it were
an AI system generating those conditions
if people would not be all outraged how
common AI system told me to accept all
these conditions I'm telling you trust
in technology rather than humans
mosha any final thought I I think we
really need to think very hard about
what makes corporations behave
unethically and it's not the people in
them I mean some of the people here from
cooperation as we serve some of I spent
a big part of my life in a cooperation
many of conferencing cooperation but
nevertheless there is something our
current economic system that makes
corporations behave legally and
ethically and that means either we need
to change the laws to make more
behaviors illegal or we need to rethink
the incentive system under which they
operate because they are just right now
in this part of our history so immensely
powerful the day behavior has huge
impact on our lives sometimes I think we
get we get caught up in the bright and
shiny and the possibilities and the
potentials of new technologies and we
forget that these technologies serve us
right and so rather than starting always
as a technology centric conversation
which is not only constantly evolving
due to innovation but also quite
alienating for a large part of the the
population who doesn't have the
technological sophistication to
participate in some of the more deeper
conversations about it we need to be
having more human centric conversations
about how humans employ technology to to
meet human objectives unfortunately in
my in my field that's human objectives
of conflict and resolving these are the
tools of violence that humans decide to
employ but in other fields whether it's
healthcare education or criminal justice
these are tools that work for us and we
need to can affirm our human values and
our objectives and our desires and what
levels of trust we're going to demand or
what what metrics we're going to use and
then ensure that our deployers and our
developers of technologies meet those
requirements because we're in charge at
least for now
[Laughter]
so with that call to action let's thank
our
panelists conversations so we're now
going to shift to one last part of our
session which is please leave the
microphone so sorry
they'll get back up there eventually
which is a final spotlight talk by
Professor Anka dragon who is an
assistant professor in electrical
engineering and computer science at UC
Berkeley and a I believe proud at least
an alumna got her PhD from here at
Carnegie Mellon and I think is proud of
that fact I hope and she at Berkeley
runs the interactive autonomy and
collaborative technologies or interact
lab which is really focused on a lot of
these questions about human and human
robot interaction how do we have robots
that actually are able to interact with
humans in ways that can support and
empower both sides which requires doing
research really at the intersections of
robotics machine learning and cognitive
science she's also helped to found the
Berkeley AI Research Lab is a COPI I of
the Center for human compatible AI and
has won multiple early career Awards and
were delighted to welcome her about to
Pittsburgh on code jargon
hi everyone pleasure to be here I am
going to basically agree with everything
that Manuel I said and maybe add one
twist so robots take actions that change
the state of the world and as we've
heard yesterday what the way they choose
the actions to take is usually via
something called a reward function or
objective function so they plan actions
that in expectation maximize cumulative
reward I think when things can go wrong
is when people have mental models of
these robots then do not match up with
reality and so I've been so there for
instance the robot is much less capable
than what the person assumes or it
doesn't take the actions that the person
thinks that the robot will take and so
I've been asked to talk about trust but
what I really want to talk about is not
so much how do we get people to trust
these systems but rather how do we
ensure alignment between the person's
mental model and reality and I think
that there's two complimentary ways to
talk about doing that on the one hand we
can work on the robot side and try to
bring the robot up to match to live up
to our expectations and I would call
that making a trust ball or trustworthy
on the other hand we could work on the
human side and bring expectations and
calibrate them right to reality my
background my personal background is
actually in transparency so I don't want
to focus so much on transparency today
but I do want to talk about it for a
couple minutes to just share some
highlights so if we talk about robots
being transparent we have to actually
define what that means and I'm gonna
propose one definition which is what
I've been using I don't think it's the
only definition but the way I've been
thinking about the problem is that
there's some internal state to the robot
like its capability its utility its what
it plans on doing and the human doesn't
get to know that but what the human can
have is some sort of estimate or belief
in what that is and that's the robot
takes actions in the world and these
actions could be physical actions or
explanation
that ends up changing the person's
estimate the person gets to observe that
and adjust their mental model over time
and so I believe that we have an
opportunity here for the robot to not
just maximize the reward that's been
given to achieve the functional task but
also reason about how its actions are
affecting the person's belief and try to
come up with actions that are that
steered the person's belief towards the
correct mental model towards reality and
that to me is what transparency means
and before I move on I just want to give
you a few examples of what that might
look like so here's a robot that is
planning to grab one of these two
bottles the one on the right and it
could do it pretty efficiently but then
it'd be kind of confusing to a person
observing which bottled the robot is
going for so what this robot is figuring
out is that by exaggerating its motion
to the right it can become more clear to
a person observing this motion what it
is that it's about to do it's not the
most efficient way but it's a way that
increases transparency by carefully
selecting actions that take the person's
belief towards the object on the right
the correct go that was my thesis at
Carnegie Mellon here we call this
legible motion in the meantime we've
generalized this to a few things so it
utilities for instance here's an
autonomous car sort of placing the
passenger in a situation and showing in
the situation I would cut this other guy
off to convey to the passenger that look
my driving style is a little bit more on
the aggressive side I do believe we have
to calibrate expectations about
capability a lot and so because people
tend to over assume so what we've been
working on is also these robots that
fail and show you the failures and show
them expressively so a robot that says
here's what I'm trying to do and it's
not working and and here's why it's not
working I'm trying to pull on this thing
but it's locked I'm trying to push this
thing but I can't do it I'm trying to
lift this Cup
but it's too heavy and then the final
example is one of a agent that plays
pong trained by a deep reinforcement
learning which is all the rage these
days what the agent is doing here is
it's showing us
how it would act in states that if
things are critical meaning states where
it thinks it's really important to take
the action that it's about to take so 4
pong this means when the ball is coming
close to you and it's at a high speed
then it's really important to move that
pellet upward down and so the agent is
showing you this so that you can build
this mental model of what it is that it
actually has learned so in a nutshell we
can enable transparency by being careful
about steering the person's belief in
the right direction but after working on
transparency for a bit I became a little
bit disappointed with it because what
transparency is about is calibrating the
person's expectation it's not working on
the person and wouldn't it be nice if we
could do some work on the robot side to
get the robot to live up to the person's
expectation as opposed to just bring the
person's expectations down in a lot of
ways this is what artificial
intelligence is all about most of the
work in AI is about making robots most
trustworthy making robots actually more
capable of doing the thing typically
that means getting robots to solve this
optimization problem how do you actually
optimize the reward that it's been given
to you but what I've been finding is
that even though this is one modality of
increasing capability there's another
thing that can go wrong which is the
reward function itself so sometimes the
reward function does not actually
correspond to what we actually want the
robot to be optimizing for and it makes
sense because the people who are
building these robots were human too
right and we're fallible and we don't
always encode the right objectives or
incentives in the robot here's a cute
example of this going wrong this is
video from open AI and this is a boat
racing agent you can't tell that it's
trying to race by looking at it the
reason is that the reward function was
score points in the game and so
on the top left there you see all the
other agents actually completing the
race what our boat does is it figures
out this loop that it can do and time it
just right so that it collects all these
turbo boosters at the right time and get
a gazillion points okay so you look at
this as designer they're like oh my god
of course this is not what I wanted of
course I wanted you to actually
participate in the race and try to win
but that's not what was specified this
is not a new problem Steve Russell and
Peter Norvig if this example and their
AI book of a vacuum cleaning robot and
the reward function could be the amount
of dust you managed to suck in and that
kind of makes sense because the more
dust that sucks in the cleaner the floor
is but then depending on the hardware
the optimal policy can be suck in a
little bit of dust and then dump it all
out then suck in a little bit more dump
it all back out right and recycle that I
don't think this is necessarily that
specific to AI think this is kind of a
general problem with with technology as
a whole and I think it comes from some
of them we all know about which is that
we were not very good at saying what we
want right we have all these myths and
legends about be careful what you wish
for and the reason it should be careful
is because you might just get it and it
might not be happy with the consequences
like King Midas wishing that everything
it touched turned to gold and I do want
to emphasize that this is not a story
about that is only applicable to Ages
that actually are capable at optimizing
their objectives I struggle with this
every day I do a lot of motion planning
work and motion planning you have to
write down a cost function that trades
off between different things that are
important to the robot this case
distance to the person and distance to
fragile objects and so on what
inevitably happens is you tune the thing
it works over 10 20 different problem
settings different environments and then
you encounter a new environment at some
point that's different enough and the
optimal behavior does not actually
correspond to what you actually wanted
so overall we're not great at specifying
these reward functions and I don't want
to make because this is an AI in ethics
conference I do want to make a little
bit of a theoretical point on ethics
which
is that I think that makes it difficult
to encode the ethical principles that we
as humans find so easy and common sense
into these machines and all us minqi as
as my helper to make this point so
Mickey Mouse this is a this is from
Fantasia Mickey Mouse was charged with
getting water from outside the house
into the home and Mickey gets tired of
this and makes a robot right uses magic
to bring a broom to life and shows it
how to do the test and Mickey goes to
bed and then Mickey wakes up and he's in
a puddle of water and he realizes that
his robot assistant was a bit
overzealous with optimizing the
objective function that he specified
what's interesting here is that Mickey
then goes and you'll see in a second he
goes and tries to stop the broom but
that doesn't work because the broom was
given an objective function and sort of
what make you suggesting is not optimal
and so kind of a best be very very basic
I'm not sure I would even call it
ethical basic principle you might want
to encode right in this reward function
is look you should do what people say
okay so I just want to point out a
theoretical level that that's not
actually that trivial so the way you
might structure this you might say
here's the normal reward function you
should optimize for this except if the
person says do something else right more
reward than doing this something else
but if you set this up to be high enough
not that I'm worried that robots would
actually figure out how to do this at
all but just theoretically I want to
point out that which of what we just did
is we provided an incentive to the robot
to try to get itself in situations where
then people would react and give it
Corrections so that it can then accept
them and cash in on all of that reward
right and similarly if you make it too
low other things happen so it's not
trivial to tune these things right even
for something as basic as do what people
say now I'm not worried about this would
robots today you know pass that they
have very narrow action spaces so they
would never figure out even if that's
the reward function how
you actually do that here's the robot it
moves from a start to a goal location
it's trying to be efficient it's trying
to optimize for staying away from things
and I it's very easy to get it to do
what I want so if I'm not happy with how
it's doing the task if for instance I
think that it's keeping the bottle the
the mug too high up what I can do is I
can just go there and push on it and it
will do the thing and I can write a
controller pretty easily maybe an
impedance controller that makes the
robot actually compliant to human touch
the interesting thing for the robot
though I know it's hard for a real robot
today is not so much accepting this kind
of oversight but figuring out what to do
with it afterwards because the moment I
let go right the robot goes back to
optimizing its objective it's its reward
function and so the moment I let go
right the robot goes back to the old way
of doing the task and I keep pushing on
it
I think e's going back and I keep
pushing at it and if it keeps going back
to what it thinks is the optimal way of
doing it and can be pretty frustrating
so with real robots I think the more
into sort of near-term problem is that
you shouldn't just be compliant you
should actually try to continually learn
from this oversight that people give you
and try to not make the same mistakes
again and again and again and so with
what all these three examples I think
teach us is that the classical AI
picture here is missing something
there's no reward function that's
exogenously specify it doesn't come from
the sky and still what we have is we
have people that want things internally
and that's what the robot should be
trying to optimize for if it's a
designer right then the designer might
actually specify a reward function but
chances are because we're human and
because we're fallible but that's not
necessarily going to match up perfectly
it's not gonna be totally drugged but
it's not gonna match up perfectly to
what people actually what the designer
actually wants internally and what we do
right now is we just take that for
granted we just plug it in and say this
is what we're optimizing for as if
humans are perfect but they're not and I
think the picture that we should really
be reasoning about is this one where you
have a robot the trust actually work
with the person to figure out what it is
that they really want and it's hard
because you know we can't actually
decode what people think internally it's
a really tough tough thing to do but I
think we can make some progress towards
that so let me give you an example of
one thing that we've been thinking about
so we're back to the boat racing game do
you remember the game with the with the
boat racing that was doing the loop so
what was happening there was essentially
the boat had the choice between winning
and getting a lot of points say 20 or
exploiting this kind of loop that it
could do get even more points but not
win and it shows the second version and
the reason it shows the second version
was because there was a designer who
said look you should optimize for score
in the game so the interesting question
is why did the designers say that right
we designers are not totally dumb right
we're not just gonna write down every
word function and deployed their sent
the robot off them to the world and hope
for the best so the reason was that the
designer actually tested this robot on
some environments and on those
environments optimizing for points got
the boat to actually do the correct
thing
so at training time the the environments
that the person actually looked at were
pretty different than this one test
environment the training time you could
actually win with a lot of points if you
had fewer points then you wouldn't win
as much or as many times or you would
lose and so score and winning were
correlated at training time but they
were no longer correlated at test time
and that's what broke things so that's
one of the things that can go wrong or
you have features that no longer
correlate things can go wrong in many
other ways here's another example say
I'm building a robot to drive around the
CMU campus and I know it's gonna have to
deal with terrain and it deals with
grass and and paved roads and dirt roads
and so on and maybe I want the robot to
stay to avoid the grass and protect it
so I have to write down a reward
function for that the robot doesn't
actually know what
grass and what's dirt and so on and so
all it has is some sensor input let's
say lidar came from camera images and so
the first thing I'll do is I'll write
down some classifiers some detectors for
this terrain types and then I'll define
my reward function that says you know
grass is bad going on dirt or pavement
is better and so I deployed the robot
after some testing and it does well in
CMU I send it to Berkeley does well in
Berkeley and then I don't know I send it
to Hawaii and then Hawaii right there's
grass there's dirt but there's maybe
some dangerous surfaces as well that I
don't want the robot to go over for
dramatic effect in this talk will refer
to these as lava right there's mountains
of lava now what the robot will do a
deployment time is it's gonna use a
three word function that I define to
evaluate the different surfaces and who
knows what it's gonna do for lava that
wasn't right and we don't have detectors
for that we totally forgot about it so
this is one thing that can another thing
that can go wrong which is maybe we
don't actually think of all the edge
cases of all the possible things that
our robots might have to face like
dangerous surfaces that don't appear at
training time but if you're at test time
so even though with the boat example and
this navigation example there are
different things that are going wrong
they have one important thing in common
which is what gives me hope and that one
thing that they have in common is that
the designer actually did a pretty good
job for the training environments in
other words there's not much that we
know about the true reward what the
person actually wants but there's one
thing that we know which is that
whatever reward function the person
specified it might not work always it
might not produce the right behavior
always but on the training environments
it produces the right behavior and
that's information that we now have
about the true reward all right we don't
have the true reward but we know this
much and in fact that adequate that's
all that we should assume if a person
specifies a reward another way of saying
the same thing is that look what we end
up specifying is contextualized in the
experiences that we have robots are not
interpreted literally right should
interpreted as being contextualized in
the experiences that we have for robot
assistant the artist mathematically the
way we do this is instead of just
optimizing the reward function we treat
it as an observation and the Bayesian
sense about the underlying true reward
and to do that we have to reason about
if theta star is the true reward if the
trade the person who is looking at the
training environment what will they
write down what is likely for them to
specify and that's where we use our
insight what we do is we say well how
likely is the beta tilde to be written
down as the specified reward
well I have to look at what behavior it
incentivizes on the training
environments and if that behavior is
good with respect to theta star then I
know that if theta star is the correct
reward theta tilde is likely to be
written down more likely to be written
down by the designer as the specified
reward so that's how we do it
intuitively what this means is as
follows going back to the boat example
imagine that there's a plethora of
different reward functions that the
person that the person might define
right so there's all these different
features that might be relevant the
person specified theta 2 which is
maximized score that's what they picked
instead of just optimizing for score
what our robot is going to do is it's
going to take a step back and say what's
the experience that they had to draw on
when they specified theta 2 let's take a
look right they looked at these
environments where you could either win
with a lot of points or lose with fewer
points and theta 2 incentivizes the
behavior where you get a lot of score
and you and you also win and so what the
robot is wondering now is for which of
all these possibilities is winning with
high score a good idea which of these
reward functions could have been the
true reward function and what you can
figure out pretty easily is that
maximizing score likes this behavior
minimizing score or trying to lose if
that were the objective that doesn't
like this behavior so you can throw that
right out but you also understand that
maximizing winning is something that
likes this behavior so now the robot
knows ok I was told to optimize for
school
I'm pretty sure the person didn't mean
to lose or to minimize score but I don't
know if they didn't mean to win because
based on the information that they had
winning also might look like a good
thing so and they might have not gotten
that so this is a very simple to example
we've been playing with situations that
are actually complicated where the robot
doesn't get convenient access to all the
important relevant fixer features like
winning we've been looking at motion
planning to where we end up with these
more robust behaviors and these
complicated new environments that the
robot is choosing and so overall I think
that was just one example of the
approaches we can take but overall what
I'd say is whether it's a designer
that's writing down a reward function or
an end user telling you that you're
doing something wrong or even actually
giving you Corrections what the robot
should be doing is taking goal of this
in as useful evidence it's useful
information about what people actually
want and what the robot is actually
supposed to do and improving that over
time and getting better and better at
optimizing not a specified reward but
what people actually want here's what
happens with our little example when you
do this I push on the robot
and instead of just going back the robot
interprets that as evidence about what I
want and it ends up doing the task very
differently so to conclude there's this
mismatch that we now have and I think
both making robots more trustworthy and
the ways that we've talked about as well
as making robots more transparent it's
going to help with not necessarily
resolving one thing or another but
bringing these these two items the real
robot and the mental model closer to
each other and have a common middle
ground that works out well for the human
and the robot with that I'd like to
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you so much you won't need the mic
so that was really wonderful and I think
especially the ways in which you focused
on reward functions as connected
directly into the end of the previous
panel this idea that we want the robots
to to support our goals in our interests
well then we have to say what counts is
success and how do we do that well that
might be very hard for us humans to do
and so how can the robot learn what we
wanted without us even knowing it but
but of course I have to ask that there's
a risk I might say and want the robot to
help me not eat lots of chocolate cake
but then it looks at what I actually do
and says boy you eat a lot of chocolate
cake so how do we help the you know are
there ways that the robots might be able
to help us overcome our own in abilities
to live by what we want that's a
fantastic question because I think
you're right that there is there is a
risk that what we end up optimizing for
and what we want the robot to do are
very different but maybe one way I'd
look at this is that our objectives are
still there I still want to be a healthy
person but I'm pretty let's say myopic
or greedy in my planning horizon right
so I end up being tempted by the
chocolate because I don't necessarily
think through in the moment of all the
implications this is gonna have or maybe
I'm just you know there's one there's
many ways to which I can be suboptimal
and what I'm going for and so I think
one important to the line of work to
take when trying to look at human
behavior and sort of back out what our
incentives are is is to account for the
fact that people are not gonna be
optimal and serve therefore their
Corrections and their actions are not
necessarily going to be what they would
if the person were actually truly
optimal perfectly optimal and what we've
been finding is that for instance if we
assume that the person
myopic right then we can do a much
better job recovering their true
objective function and sort of kind of
controlled experiments then if we assume
that they weren't right so so I think
it's important for robots to actually
take these biases that we might have and
they're different ones they're just
planning fallacy there's all sorts of
different biases that people have but
but maybe that's one way to think about
it and that would enable the robot not
necessarily to identify what do we want
to be healthy or not but I think the key
to what I was talking about is really
get the right uncertainty right it's not
like the robot knows whether winning or
score is the right one it's not like the
robot knows that lavas bad right it just
knows that given what you've said
there's not enough evidence of either
way and it has uncertainty about those
and there's there's things that it
doesn't have uncertainty about because
they don't match up at all it's not
they're not possible hypotheses being
able to recognize some of those known
unknown having something become a known
unknown to use the language from
America's talk that's right so I wonder
could you also use these same sorts of
techniques to handle potential
challenges where the robot has to
interact with multiple people so the
robot has to learn you know interacts
with you interacts with me and we might
have different reward functions where it
has to learn what's in common what's
different between us with the same kind
of techniques be usable for that
challenge good so one thing that we've
experimented with is if the robot can
learn from many people when it sees a
new person it shouldn't start from
scratch right so for instance we did
this in the context of say driving
styles right so I want the car to
customize to how you want to drive how
they want to drive how they want to
drive and when I see the end person I
don't want to start they're sort of
learning from scratch because there's
common things that all people share and
then there's individual differences and
so one way I think about this is to
learn from your from all of your
previous users and build in a sense of
prior for for what you should expect
going in and then let that new person's
actions sort of and take those in as
evidence and turn that priority
so can thereby sort of find what's
similar among all of us while still
allowing for the fact that people do
drive differently or want the robot arm
to move differently the kind of
individual customization that's right
that's right but I do want to bring up a
related point that I struggle with which
is the car has multiple passengers which
driving style should I choose I put a
robot in a home and there's different
people who all have different
preferences which of them right what
combination I think all the tools that I
was talking about and all everything
that I've done has been very much along
the line of one one person one robot and
the robot is trying to learn these sort
of the internal objective that the
person wants the robot to be optimizing
and I don't know what to do when there's
multiple people I mean there's simple
things you could do like you could take
averages you could do sort of risk
averse you could do min max you could do
max min there's things like that but I
don't know what the right answer is well
I think in fairness to you
I don't think social scientists no I
don't think political scientists no I
mean this is sort of the ubiquity
ubiquitous problem in human experiences
what do you have when you're conflicting
values and conflicting interests I think
it's okay if robot assists haven't
solved this problem for us yet but we'll
look forward to it in a few years and I
guess speaking of a few years I'm
curious what do you see is sort of the
biggest opportunities for trust AI
robotics sort of in this space over the
next let's say five to ten years I think
I'm gonna go with basically Eli's answer
because I feel like as AI capability
advances and I'm much more pessimistic
about the degree of that advanced than
other people are but I think we are
making progress I think with that we get
this opportunity to help people be
better at the things that they do so you
know kind of talking about what we were
saying earlier where people tend to be
myopic well one thing that we found is
that it when the robot is on the same
team with you and you're trying to do it
together if the robot acknowledges that
you maybe don't tend to think ten steps
ahead it can sort of organize the world
and take actions in such a way that when
you then react to those actions that
reaction is good globally as well simple
example because I think what I'm saying
is very abstract it can be as simple as
when I give when the robot gives you an
object okay take it okay you take it in
the most comfortable way for you now
imagine you had an actual goal like you
have to put in a dishwasher or something
right we don't tend to necessarily think
ahead to the goal
we just we do the thing right not always
and not for everyone but especially if
we're wrapped up with other things and
one thing that the robot could do is can
be reasoning about that and then he and
you the thing sort of in a way where it
makes sure that the way you then grab it
is then conducive to your goal so use
things you still react myopically but
the robot is setting things up such that
you're actually better at the task
because of its actions or another thing
is going back to explain ability it'd be
nice and I think people are doing that
because robots are getting better and
better things like go and so on and
whatever other tasks better than human
capability it'd be nice if that made us
better as well so robot could kind of
help you make these decisions and say if
you do this just be careful that you
know 10 moves from now you might end up
here and here's why and then the person
can learn from that
and get better and so so just to
conclude the more speculative question
so in say 10 years when we're on I guess
that would be the sixth CMU K&L gates
conference how is it going to be
different how do you think things are
going to have changed either socially or
in this that we're talking about here I
guess my prediction would be that we're
gonna start talking even more about what
I might call model Mis specification so
that's one thing that I kind of foresee
being very worried about because so what
do you mean right
so we talked a lot about trying to
figure out what people want and I'm
worried that oftentimes the space that
we're we're always looking at a kind of
a closed world assumption here are the
possible things even if they're defined
on sort of raw information you're the
possible things that a person could want
and I just worried that we don't have
even observations about things that
people care about that influence what
they want and so kind of model Mis
specification drawing these inferences
over a closed world when we just we in
fact have no way of knowing basically
leads to lead can lead to issues another
thing they can lead to issue is just
inherent ambiguity where I really can't
figure out based on what you're doing or
what you're saying if you want this or
better that so then I'm sort of I need
to be risking risk-averse or
conservative but that's the best I can
do the other thing that I think will
change is is maybe the hype for AI will
die down and we'll get welcome to focus
much more on these very kind of I don't
know near-term very practical ethical
issues and I think this particular
conference is a really good job with
that but I've been at kind of other
types of events where it's you know it's
sort of very far out that everyone's
worried that in 10 years artificial
general intelligence will happen and I
think my prediction is that you know it
won't and then the hype will be a little
more reduced then we'll be able to talk
about real kind of what yellow is saying
you know real kind of narrow AI that
does something really useful which can
both empower and and cause challenges
for people that's right well thank you
so much this is really wonderful
and this this concludes our session on
trust I invite you all to stay and have
lunch in the back room please feel free
to come back up to these tables is
perfectly fine to have food and beverage
here and we will be starting back up at
noon with our session on policy and
governance thanks
[Music]
you